قال حسن الزواج الامين العام للجنه العليا
للمشاريع والارز انا دعوات المقاطعه
وحمالات التحريض الخارجيه على قطر تخفي
صوره النمطيه سيئه عن العرب عامه واشار
الزواج خلال مشاركته في برنامج للقصه بقيه
على قناه الجزيره ان كثيرا من الاطراف لم
تتقبل بعد فكره ان تفوز الدوله العربيه
بشرف تنظيم كاس العالم
دوله عربيه
اخر عشر سنين همم بالنسبه للناس كثار اي
اي همم اشاعه تقال سلبيه همم ترسخ في
بالناس لان هي التواكب ال- ال- ال- الفكره
النبطيه اللي موجوده في بعضهم سهل ان شخص
مش مثلا في شوارع انجلترا او شوارع فرنسا
ان يصدق ان مثلا همم
ان فزنا بسبب الفساد وهذا كان ملف فعلا
جديد بالفوز
والشورى حسن الذوادي الا ان تنظيم كاس
العالم في قطر من شانه ان يغير جذريا
الصوره النمطيه عن العرب وهو ما سيمثل
ابرز اهداف تنظيم هذا الحدث الكبير
قوه كاس العالم بشكل عام هي في تقارب
الشعوب وتقارب الجماهير بينهم وبين بعض
هذه هذه يمكن بالنسبه لي يعني سر النجاح
البطوله وتصير تغيير الفكره النبطيه اولا
الناس من الخارج يشوفون طبعا
والنفسهم راح يشوفهم دوله راح يشوفوا
الناس من جميع الاطياف جميع الاجناس
فرحانين وجايين همم يشجعون او تكون مثل
كرنفال الكروي وكارنافال ثقافي موجود لكن
بدرجه اساسيه الشعوب اللي تيجي الناس اللي
كانت على السفر لاول مره في الوطن العربي
بعضهم يمكن اول مره يزور الوطن العربي
والتعامل ويمكن يعني راح يتعرفون على
الثقافه العربيه على الكرم العربي على
الفخر العربي موجود عندنا على غزاره
الثقافه اللي موجوده عندنا هذه النقطه
اساسيه بالنسبه لنا
همم في في تغيير الصوره النبطيه اللي
موجوده